scepticism is the realization of that of
which stoicism was only the notion and
is the actual experience of what the
freedom of thought is this is in itself
the negative and must exhibit itself as
such with the reflection of
self-consciousness into the simple
thought of itself the independent
existence or permanent to terminus that
stood over against that reflection has
as a matter of fact fallen outside of
the infinitude of thought in skepticism
now the holy unassessed
and non independent character of this
other becomes explicit for consciousness
the abstract thought becomes the
concrete thinking which annihilates the
being of the world and all its manifold
determinate 'no sand the negativity of
free self-consciousness comes to know
itself in the many and varied forms of
life as a real negativity it is clear
that just as stoicism corresponds to the
notion of the independent consciousness
which appeared as the Lord and bondsmen
relationship so scepticism corresponds
to its realization as a negative
attitude towards other Ness to desire
and work but although desire and work
were unable to effect the negation for
self consciousness this polemical
bearing towards the manifold
independence of things will on the other
hand be successful because it turns
against them as a free self
consciousness that has already completed
its own self more specifically because
it is thinking or is in its own self
infinite and Emmas infinitude the
independent things and their differences
from one another are for it only
vanishing magnitudes the differences
which in the pure thinking of self
consciousness are only the abstraction
of differences here becoming the
entirety of the differences and the
whole of differentiated being becomes a
difference of self consciousness
in paragraph 202 we're now entering into
the study of yet another shape of
consciousness that which angle is going
to according to convention called
skepticism now this is a pretty
important transition point and a rather
dense paragraph even though it's fairly
short so I want to spend a bit of time
on this a little bit more than I would
with other paragraphs and talking a
little bit about history and about some
of the other parts of the text that this
is connected to
now what Hegel is calling skepticism has
a world historical existence in the West
there is in fact you notice I've got all
these these things up on the board there
are varieties of skepticism that appear
within philosophical perspectives but
also within many other perspectives
where the philosophy is rather implicit
and what's going on is a transition and
thinking like he says here scepticism is
the realization of that of which
stoicism was only the notion so we have
to figure out well what does that mean
and how does that take place with with
these different varieties of skepticism
Hegel and self is also going to
distinguish several different types of
scepticism earlier on in the work you
remember back to the introduction and
paragraph 78 which we'll look at him in
just a moment very briefly now why is
skepticism so important let me put a
purin on the table before there's a
radicalization of these themes of
thought and freedom and negation there
is a like I just said a historical
significance
to this there is a real-life school of
philosophy that you know for example
academic skepticism then we see
asserting itself and then taking an
important role in the debates between
philosophical schools including
attacking the Stoics also attacking the
Epicureans notice too that Hegel doesn't
talk in this section of the
phenomenology about the other Koreans
who were the 3rd major new school
appearing on the scene in the
Hellenistic age of philosophy you may
ask yourself well why doesn't he
I'm going to just briefly say he thinks
that they're they're not concerned with
this development of thought they
employed thought but in many respects
the Epicureans are not advancing the
dialectic they're just they're just you
know doing something and it has to do
with prudential management of your
desires and your pleasures in skepticism
we're going to see something much
different Hegel thinks that an important
advance is being made here through
skeptic philosophy through the skeptic
attitude towards things and it's not
just a in an abstract philosophical
position it's one that actually reaches
out into the world or reaches out into
as we call it before light but it takes
a particular attitude towards it that is
transformative of consciousness it's not
going to be a final resting place
interestingly for you know what we have
historically quite a few of these people
either so on that skepticism
not be a final resting place and went
beyond it or they took it to be a final
resting place and despaired of ever
finding some sort of reliable knowledge
we might also add to this other
philosophical movements not only in the
West but also in what we call Eastern
philosophy or non Western philosophy
it's probably a better way to talk about
it because whenever we look at any of
the major world cultural systems besides
that of Western Europe and the things
that are within its orbit what we find
are similar developments of thought
Hegel by the way this is a sort of sign
how Hegel tended to think that the East
as they call that was just merely
despotic freedom wasn't really developed
you didn't have any any dialectical
development to speak of there are little
bits of things here as in Persians or
Islam but it's really a minor scale and
that's in part because Hegel didn't have
access to much of the literature that we
now possess and that they were going to
possess in just a few generations were
we able to work Hegel able to take that
what a beauty he would have recognized
certain things in Indian philosophy for
example or the in Chinese philosophy
that we're doing something quite similar
to what is going on here with the
transformation of consciousness in
skepticism so before we actually look at
what's going on in the text I want to
talk about some of these things here he
says okay this is in the text and that
skepticism is the realization of what
stoicism was essentially just starting
out the notion remember notion for Hegel
has two sides to right there's notion
here as the become if that's fully
developed where everything is totally
articulated and connected up and the
subject is involved in the act
knowing it's also active so that there's
some sort of you know change going on
within the human person within the
relation of the world within society and
then there is the big gorilla the
concept the notion as a abstract idea
that yeah has to be worked out and
stoicism is essentially over here as
something that you know
did he have some dynamism to it
represented in advance
in terms of the the negative but didn't
go that far and we saw it found her upon
some of its own internal problematics
skepticism it is going to you know to
use the old expression pull the rug out
or drop the floor out and we're going to
look down into a kind of abyss that we
didn't suspect was there until we began
to exercise their thinking and the
question is is that all there is
or it can we move past that in some way
it's very important to remember that the
skeptics in large part were not about
being skeptical for its own sake any
more than the Greek cynics who by the
way I think you could also place in this
given what Hegel is saying we're
interested in being you know provocative
for its own sake that wasn't the whole
point of it they were in search of
something in the case of the cynics they
were in search of a simple life and
virtue in the case of the skeptics they
were in a search of truth but also
virtue and goodness the way that the
Stoics thought they have a lock on they
are seeking they are the the ones in
quest and so if you want to move beyond
where you are you have to be able
to sort deep familiarize or denaturalize
the perspective that you're taking so
you realize how arbitrators and you can
move somewhere else and that's what the
skeptics were in fact doing you also
have to test everything that is being
presented to you whether it's an
argument or a sense perception or an
ethical norm or some mythology you have
to put it to the test and see whether it
can withstand the scrutiny of thought
and its capacity its corrosive capacity
for negation for determinate negation in
this case a hail doesn't is not going to
use that term here but we should think
of what the skeptics did as in many
respects determinate negation so here we
have a person called pyro he's sort of
an independent free agent although he
ends up developing a whole school of
people around them and interestingly if
you read diogenes laërtius either I
strongly suggest that you read Diogenes
Lera takes light of pirates a very short
section it will tell you not only about
this guy and his own thought processes
and his doctrines but also about the
followers that he drew and about the
debate over what they should be called
and the the further debates and
questions over whether we can even
really say that we know what his
doctrines were because here's an
interesting thing once you open the door
to skepticism this is where people like
to current post Colin Hume and the
modern period are confronting something
that's internal to the nature of
skepticism once you really open the door
to skepticism all bets are off you start
to question all sorts of things
including the very basis for skepticism
or our knowledge about the people who
originated it if you're going to be anti
dogmatic you have to be anti dogmatic
consistently because if you're not going
to be that way the guy next to you will
do it and he'll be a better skeptic than
you will there is an internal logic to
skepticism that produces this sort of
paradise now the academics that's
Plato's school the Academy at a certain
point in time they go from what we might
call Orthodox Platonism and remember by
this time they'd already spun off
Aristotle's Lyceum basically by not
giving him the next in line jobs for
Aristotle like anybody else who's hyper
talented goes off it starts its own
concern but the Academy Aminah veering
into a type of skepticism and the
academic sceptics ended up becoming the
great opponents in debate not only of
Aristotle school but also of the Stoics
and the Epicureans in Athens in in
Rhodes in Alexandria in the entire Roman
Empire once these things had spread out
these debates take place and the
skeptics distinguished themselves in
part by being able to bring up arguments
against whatever positions somebody else
is holding without without necessarily
committing themselves to that argument
they're just saying we'll look there's
another way of looking at this there's
another side to this and this is a very
important movement to the thought it's
the realization that we can in fact
bring up all sorts of objections you
know when people are saying they're
playing devil's advocate usually they're
just being a jerk and I sent a stuff
about this in other videos so don't
bother commenting about it go track it
down the fine discussions about that
usually it's because of what he would
call self-willed
or a kind of stubbornness and wanting to
stir the pot but sometimes this
questioning for the sake of questioning
can be extreme
useful in provoking people to think and
shading them up that's what the devil's
advocate says that he or she is about
but quite often it's not really that's
the circle the facade of it in any case
the academics before there is a sort of
veering back in middle Platonism to you
know genuine platanus things then you
come up with all these interesting
theories about what can be known and
what can't be known and whether all of
our understanding of things is really
just probable what our criteria could be
for for knowledge they're engaged in
some pretty hardcore epistemology the
ancient period readings if you want to
see some of their doctrines in a
particularly well-developed form read
Cicero's academics sexist and pure
against another philosopher who is
important in the history of skepticism
he he's also important for our knowledge
of other philosophical positions and
schools because in trying to argue
against them he does portray their
position which is you know good because
we've lost a lot of their their works he
also is doing this this thing and he
forms sort of you might say stock of
particular ways in which one can go
about making arguments against positions
scepticism is always with us it's always
lurking in the background but it comes
to the fore again in the modern period
of course there were you know people
writing about skepticism in the the
medieval period just you know read some
of the authors like st. Augustine for
example but with the curves and Paschal
and Hume I think you have three people
who are particularly concerned with this
problem of scepticism decart will
actually harness skepticism as a
principal we all know about the current
methodological
and if you've read the meditations or
you've even read the discourse which is
a rather adumbrated version of it
meditations is probably worth that worth
reading for that you see just how far
Descartes is willing to take doubt what
Hegel hasn't mind here is there in the
ancient skeptics but it's further
radicalized in somebody like Nick Hart
from whom the entire world of perception
and the world of our ideas about say
laws of nature or the laws governing
mathematics might all just be famous
within our own mind or you know the
clause by some other source like an evil
genius planting these ideas in her head
past all himself is extremely troubled
by skepticism and although he has an
Orthodox religious believer some say
he's actually a Jansen s but I think
there's evidence that then he's not a
Jansen of soluti and a lot of Jansen's
friends he's an Orthodox Catholic he is
concerned with grappling with skepticism
and the skepticism of his own time which
they current plays a part in but which
many other people are experiencing which
is you know having them turned to things
like variety of hedonism and we call
libertinism or to stoicism there were
many other skeptics and and Pascal
himself is worried about sort of falling
into this gulf of skepticism so he he
explores it David Hume of course best
known perhaps for you know being the
father if he is indeed the father the is
a lot of this station that's really in
many respects the
interesting thing in his work brilliant
thinker he discusses academic skepticism
any more of us says that's a little bit
too excessive but it also comes to the
conclusion in his works that we really
can't know much of anything except based
on experience and so we can't be
completely certain all of that he says
now these skeptical doubts as soon as I
step outside of my chamber they go away
and I don't have to worry about that so
the cure for that is get yourself out in
the world and connect up with other
people and things and you know the these
skeptical doubts won't go away but then
when you're sitting by yourself they
creep back in unless you know really is
it something that you see recurring over
and over in Humes thought his visit the
way of addressing this was to say you
know human nature actually provides us
with some sort of hard and fast basis
you know human nature is the same there
as it is here we have to assume that it
was the same in antiquity as it is by us
but you know if you start applying
scepticism those sorts of things fall
apart so if you use him sort of against
Humes of tendencies it is very
legitimate to drawsome quite skeptical
conclusions from his philosophy and that
indeed is what is supposed to woken
Conte up from his dogmatic slumbers
reading him and realizing that causality
cause and effect were not as ironclad as
we thought them to be it could be called
into question it could be doubted and
arguments could be brought up and as you
in fact did to say that no it's just the
effect of habit or custom customary
connection constant you know conjoining
of these two things makes us think that
one thing causes another so all of that
said skepticism is on the scene Hegel is
also talking about skeptic
in paragraph 78 and I just want to say
just a few things about that very
quickly he starts out talking about
natural consciousness that's the sort of
everyday attitude that we're in and it
doesn't really have knowledge if it's
going to acquire knowledge it's going to
be through the pathway of doubt and
despair which is what skepticism is
going to bring up on the scene
so Hegel will say this thoroughgoing
skepticism is not the skepticism with
which an earnest field for truth and
science fancies it has prepared and
equipped itself in their service so
there's more than one kind of skepticism
the resolve in science not to give
oneself forward to the thoughts of
others mere Authority but to examine
everything for oneself and follow only
one's own conviction or better still to
produce everything went south and accept
only ones own deed as what is true so
these are these are multiple forms of
skepticism you know what he says what
he's saying is different than that is
this shilly-shallying about this or they
have presumed truth followed by a return
of the truth again after the donor has
been appropriately dispelled so at the
end of the process the matter is taken
to what be what it was in the first
place he also talks a little bit later
you know about this this issue of being
caught up in a system of opinions and
prejudices based on personal conviction
and being caught up in wanna based on
the authority of others he says the
skepticism that's directed against the
whole range of phenomenal consciousness
on the other hand was a different kind
random is the spirit for the first time
incompetent to examine what truth is
before it brings about here we get the
negative again a state of despair about
all the so-called natural light
his thoughts and opinions regardless of
whether they are called one's own or
someone's else so what do we have going
on here let's let's think now I'm back
to stoicism right stoicism was a
withdrawal from from this whole you know
booming buzzing confusion of life a way
in which the the being the self could
assert gets its freedom by you know
retreating into abstract thought and
their might nullify the relationship
between master and slave while leaving
it in place it also nullifies the world
but it does so on the basis that's
rather unstable because it is still
there is still some content there within
the self this this criterion of the true
the good and rationality what's going to
happen in skepticism this even that is
going to get called into question that's
part of what he's saying here with
skepticism is the realization of that of
which stoicism was only the notion and
it says further it's the actual
experience of what the freedom of
thought is what why is that the case
well when you're able to reflexively
realize that you can call into question
you can do you know D substance affine
we might say if I'm quite a crazy phrase
we can say this this is possibly false
not only what other people are telling
us not only what the world is supplying
us in terms of sense perceptions or
ideas about the way things work but even
our own ideas when we can say I'm not
even sure those things are reliable we
deepen the the doubt and that in
prodigiously he said is a kind of
despair that we're gonna see talked
about again so he goes on he says this
isn't itself a negative and must exhibit
its
such stoicism negated but did not
exhibit itself as a negative skepticism
is going to show itself as the negative
with the reflection of
self-consciousness into the simple
thought of itself the independent
existence or permanent determinate nough
stats tunna against that reflection has
as a matter of fact fallen outside of
the infinitude of thought so what is he
talking about here the infinitude of
thought is over here and what was
presenting itself as independent as
essential turns out not to be so
precisely because of the agency of the
free self in thinking it so he says
there's a being pushed outside of the
infinitude of thought and then there's
going to be is we're gonna see a sort of
recuperation movement bringing it back
with them says some skepticism now the
holy uh nacelle and non independent
character of this other becomes explicit
for consciousness the conscious free
self in thought says to the other you
are not essential I don't know what you
are but you don't really matter and
you're probably not what you're
pretending to be I don't even know if
you are I'm gonna make sure that you
exist
you're not independence you're not
independent of the stance that I myself
have towards you whether it be in
perception and understanding and any any
sort of moment of that sort so he says
the abstract thought becomes the
concrete thinking which annihilates the
being of the world and all of its
manifold determinist so it's not just
the other it is the whole world of
others all tearing other nests in self
that is being pushed over there and
which the person is
you know here's here's a term that the
Stoics actually used that we see push
roll re appropriating this is called the
negation for Hegel the skeptics called
this M okay sort of a you know
withdrawal from the things taking the
reality back they're suspending is a
better way of doing it in any case this
is an active stance that the skeptic is
taking he says abstract thought becomes
the concrete thinking which annihilates
the being of the world and all its
manifold determinate us and the
negativity of free self-consciousness
comes to know itself in the many and
varied forms of life as a real
negativity so it's by negating all this
other stuff that I get to know who and
what I am concretely this takes place by
my abstracting myself from the
determinate matrix of relations in which
I have been placed so if I have an
ancient Corinthian I can tell myself I
am NOT just a Corinthian I happen to
have been born here but that doesn't
really matter my thinking can be done
just as well
over at Epirus or in Rome as I'm doing
it here in Corinth that doesn't make any
difference we can abstract away from any
concrete determinant this that happens
to be what you know we're concerned with
her what's presenting itself to us so he
says it's clear that just as stoicism
corresponds to the notion of the
independent consciousness which appeared
to the Lord and bondsmen relationship so
scepticism corresponds to its
realization an important point their
notion and realization realization as a
negative attitude towards other Ness to
desire and work its way on disengaging
oneself from the matrix of reality in
which one finds oneself originally and
asserting no reality lies on this side
the fact that I can say no the fact that
I could undermine the fact that I can
call into question renders this side
priority that this side cannot match so
he goes on they says although desire and
were unable to affect the negation for
self consciousness the master-slave
dialectic didn't pay off in that respect
and neither did stoicism this political
berry this this attitude of polemicist
fighting right towards the manifold
independence of things will never even
be successful why because it turns
against them is a free self
consciousness that is already complete
in its own self this is what stoicism
was attempting to do according to Hegel
skepticism is actually able to bring it
off at least for the moment we're gonna
see that this this you know idea that
there's a free self consciousness that's
already completed its own self that's
not actually going to hold up over time
but but that's what it gets to think for
the moment right so any he goes around
he says there we go more specifically
because of this thing it or isn't its
own self infinite and then this
infinitive the independent things of
their differences from one another are
for an only vanishing man magnitude so
in the world right the world on
voluntary and between these different
others because they're all others to
this and there are also others to each
other there are differences now what is
the status of those differences they
become as Hegel says here vanishing man
things that turn into just you know
tribute we could say that's another way
of translating vanishing magnitudes
trivial things that don't really matter
the differences he says which are which
in the pure thinking of
self-consciousness are only the
abstraction of differences so as some
consciousness now is extending itself
out and thinking there's these
differences become abstractions of
differences they become now the entirety
of the differences and the whole of
differentiated being becomes a
difference of self-consciousness so what
does that mean all of this exists as
it's being has the reality that it has
only at this point in time for self
consciousness again a total
prioritization of this polarity this
pole of the the salt and other the other
is and the other is what it is in its
differences with other others only as it
is for the free self for the thinking
self for the skeptic
you